hey guys what's up this is andrew for
trinsens.com so in this video i would
like to go with you through all this
week's price action on amc i know that
not all of you guys are on this code
where i press daily updates about what
is happening on amc and gamestop so i
would like here to sum up a bit the
situation and let you know what i think
will happen next let's get into it
[Music]
all right guys so first as usual we take
a step back we're gonna daily time frame
so let me here quickly remind you what
is happening for the past you know three
six months so basically we had this huge
move up to 73 that was following fibs
and any other theory very well this is
the reason why i will keep applying
these tools on this stock then we had
here this very long correction period
that was not easy to trade we had one
fake out and then here we had the
breakout guys all right so this was in
august so of course i told you that this
is a very good and bullish signal and
that probably is going to be retested
and then we would move higher which is
what happened so from here
let's zoom in a little bit let's go on a
forward time frame what can we say guys
what we can see we are looking for five
waves development so the truth is that
you know it could have happened right
away all right it was one of the
scenarios that we do one two three four
five right away 230 but definitely the
way things look right now it shows us
that it's gonna take more time
and we can see that here it looks to me
like the first wave of this five waves
development that to me is going to 130
or 100 minimum it might even be higher
actually if we take much time to go
there so it is good as well you know
that this fifth wave is longer in time
than expected so this counting was not
easy i was first checking maybe here we
have five waves
so i was first checking here if you have
five ways and then we had this one more
wave up and i was starting to tell you
guys that we have this bearish
divergence on my discord okay so i told
you this i started to tell you guys this
quite early here and then we have this
one more move up and then we move down
so to me this is what makes me think
that this is first wave and that we are
now in a second wave correction and we
had all these patterns all right candle
information patterns that are quite easy
to identify so we had first the evening
star guys whenever you have an evening
star it's gonna impact the press action
for at least one week and the good news
is that just after the evening star what
did we have guys we had hammer so it's
kind of information that is coming to
cancel the impact of the evening star
right here a lot of bears have been
trapped so evening star hammer and
shooting star alright guys so what this
is telling us it tells us that the
market doesn't know that we are in the
period of consolidation after this first
wave so this is confirming my scenario
that we are actually in a wave too so if
it's second wave that is corrective we
have a lot of information about that we
know that it's probably going to be an
abc flat or zigzag i was waiting to see
how high the b wave might go it didn't
go very high it went to 48 49
so this is rather telling me that we
have a zigzag coming guys i'm here to
tell you the truth so it's of course it
might very well find support at 44 but
it might as well break it and if it does
it's totally fine because we know how
zigzags develop it's probably going to
be a one-to-one relation between a and b
so if it's a one-to-one it goes to 40
and if it's a 1 to 0.618 which is
possible as well it's only going to go
to the 43 level so something between 40
and 43. so this is only an area right
fibs is giving you areas once again i
get this information guys from here
for those who have not seen this yet you
go to the 78th page
and here we can see a zigzag typically
abc has a one to one relationship
between wave a and with c but somewhere
else in the book you can have a look at
that guys it's a one two open 618
relation as well considered as valid so
here it gives us some target for the
bottom of wave too so for those who want
to buy the dip i think this is a nice
opportunity so we're going to have here
all this area that is going to be a
buying area i'm saying that if we go
there it's a nice level to buy let's see
what is happening here for me for this
correction to be over first we need a
bit more time you can see that wave one
lasted one month so just give it some
time let's see at the end of the week
where we are but basically if we have a
weekly close above 48 this would start
to be good news for the coming third
wave now let's have quickly a look at
the synthetic shot interest as usual we
have the option expiry so let's see how
this happened so we were roughly at 20
so i'm not that surprised we lost a bit
of options because september was a big
big expiry and everything has not been
rolled yet so we can have a look at
october how is it looking now so i added
here the 1st of october 24th of
september oh 24th of september we have a
lot guys where is it coming from no but
you can see this the big ones they are
jan 22
so once again
this is only an indication about for how
long
the upside the gamma is with us oh here
we have one
okay so basically we have october
70 strike october is quite big
and then gen 22 guys options everywhere
even here
on the 20 strike okay so those are
probably been some option buyers that
were in early so here basically the
information we have is that for now we
don't see all the option open interest
rolled on the next maturity october is
not so big yet so i'm going to keep an
eye on this we can see that the gen 22
maturity is full guys let's see the gen
23
okay it's not that big you can see here
we have 75 000 option total here we have
270 000 options so
this phenomenon is gonna last at least
until gen 22 and probably even longer so
this is a long-term battle guys that is
looking quite well to me we just having
a small pullback but i think we are
still pushing higher and that amc is
going to be trading much higher in a few
weeks month so that's it for me i hope
you enjoyed this video and if you did
please don't forget to click on the sub
like and bell button so you're gonna be
the first to know when i upload anything
new and stay close to shore see you guys